c'est qu'il sait imiter des chanteurs il
fit qui sait imiter les chanteurs à la
personne personne ne signifie faire ça
de matthieu delormeau moussa imiter
personne
johnny danseurs alesi aux banques oui
ç'a eu ces données
non parce que j'ai pas j'ai pas bien le
dire une jolie passe et je vais juste
passé johnny maeschalck pas je vais pas
craquer quoi ses confrères hésite donc
c'était bien ouais alors je vais
entendre les routes volent et salue ces
données jean luc jean luc je sais que
vous y sera limitée au moins avec ces
barques olivier fogiel poète on le fera
c'est au ps j'adore je vois pas pourquoi
vous poser cette question alors cyril
hanouna proposer un côté matthieu
delormeau est ce que c'est parce qu'il a
des capacités pour faire des pompes et
pour faire une imitation le clos tous à
l'électro françois bon ouais pareil la
bande de l'emprunt
et puis concordia l'acsor à naxos la
pendule décalé je me dis justement
montré précis où tu vas dit despatie et
puis tu les papiers j'ai senti tout
exotisme d'écouté côtés de candidats
locaux au moment l'électrocution c'est
bizarre il était quelqu'un moutarde ou
un peu à les faire brûler autant c'est
bon c'est bon on a compté cette année
c'est une catastrophe non mais ça
arrange illimité maïté de temps en temps
c'est un conseil mais en faisant night
été pendant de maitre gims soit 1,10 m
gibbs avait le droit de mcgill
sapé comme jamais non c'est pas mal du
tout merci